it's quite difficult to get into places
like this have to remove everything
metallic and not even wearing a belt and
bit worried that my trousers might fall
down that would be a first for periodic
videos I'm really excited
I've got here more than one and a half
million pounds worth of platinum group
metals never had so many in front of me
all at once and we here at Johnson
Matthey noble metals and they've allowed
us to see all sorts of parts of the
factory but just a warm-up as a sort of
site so we have here five kilos of gold
and another five kilos in a packet these
are each worth a hundred and fifty
thousand pounds so reasonable house just
to get started we're here at a place
where they are processing these metals
here rhodium iridium palladium and
platinum and the reason that they're
called noble metals is that they don't
react with oxygen easily in fact
platinum is one that really even at high
temperature doesn't form oxides the
other ones can form oxides Gold doesn't
form oxides Gold is over here and is
close to these but it's not normally
considered a platinum group metal
noble is an old-fashioned word meaning
it doesn't react posh way of saying
chemically boring the noble gases they
didn't think reacted with anything now
they know some of them do but Noble is
dismissing them as being worthy but
boring the important thing about the
noble metals the platinum group metals
is they're fantastic catalysts they can
be used for all sorts of applications
making nitric acid cleaning up car
exhausts and many other applications so
of course in all this processing they
generate dust and most of its caught but
some of it you can't avoid going into
the air and falling to the floors so
some of it collects on our shoes so when
you go in and out
they have special brushes to clean the
bottom of your shoes and they recover
really quite a large amount of metal
each year worth more than a decent sized
car what they're doing in this Factory
is taking this material which is called
sponge which is what comes from the
mines this is platinum sponge here and
in this bottle here is rhodium sponge
and it's much finer because rhodium is
the last element to come out of the
process in the mines so they take this
sponge and turn it into grains rather
like this here are grains of platinum
this is probably the only time in my
life that I will be able to play with
platinum in such a casual way and over
here I'll use the other hand so I don't
mix them up are similar sort of grains
of iridium but they're very much heavier
they turn this sponge into those grains
by heating it up to high temperature
melting it and then pouring the molten
liquid out and it's fantastic you see
this liquid that's so hot it's bright
red and then it's cooled down rapidly to
form the grains and then the grains can
be taken and melted and cast into an
ingot
a large lump and here we have an ingot
of platinum this weighs 13 kilos and you
can see I can't lift it up with one hand
with two hands I can just about start
lifting it the difference between this
and gold is that you can use platinum as
a catalyst for all sorts of chemical
processes so ingots like this are then
turned into bars like so first of all by
hammering the ingot very hard with a
heavy hammer when it's really hot and
the fantastic thing is as it hammers it
the metal gets hotter the energy of the
hammer is turned into heat it starts
glowing redder and redder and then they
take the hammered bar and draw it down
through a series of dyes so it first of
all gets into a coil like this and as
the coil comes out of the dye it coils
itself up it's almost like magic you see
this coming up and going round and round
and round I was mesmerised
and then they take this heavier bar and
put it through a series of days till in
some processes it gets narrower than my
hair I didn't actually take out a head
to measure but I believed them and I
couldn't see it easily though Brady is
much better with his lens and saw it
once they've got these fibers these
wires they can then start making all
sorts of materials they can knit the
fibers together or weave them just like
you do with cloth to make fine meshes
which are used in the chemical industry
for catalyzing reactions particularly
for example turning ammonia into nitric
acid this process that we've all read
about in books ammonia going to nitric
acid but actually to see these huge
pieces of fiber woven together and
what's so interesting is that they're so
thin you imagine when you say huge
chemical plant that it's full of
catalysts whereas in fact the operating
catalyst is really quite thin and the
reaction takes place very fast and you
need the rest to warm it up and cool it
down afterwards it's important to stress
that in the mines for the platinum group
metals and the main mines are in South
Africa in Russia some in the Zimbabwe
and some in Canada in all these places
the amount of platinum group metals in
the rock is very very small to make an
ounce of this sponge you require
somewhere between 10 and 40 tonnes of
rock a huge amount and the other thing
is the processing is not instantaneous
once you've got the rocks out to get the
Platinum material takes about six weeks
of processing letting things settle
processing some more and rhodium takes
another 14 weeks so perhaps 20 weeks
nearly half a year to get the rhodium
once you've dug the rocks to this stage
but once it gets here they can process
really quite quickly some of the samples
when we saw when we arrived are already
being processed had to get us another
ingot of platinum the one we saw was
already gone into the factory 94 percent
platinum and six percent rhodium and
part of the reason for this is that
rhodium is a much rarer element and also
that people have found that platinum
with a bit of rhodium gives particularly
good